[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Henkin job or
as I prefer to think of it Dear John and
Hank it's a podcast where me and my
brother John answer your questions give
you to be his advice and bring you all
the week's news from both Mars and AFC
Wimbledon hey it's been a big week for
AFC Wimbledon actually it hasn't yeah
there's not that much news from AFC
Wimbledon is there is there a lot of
news from Mars or should people just
stop listening to the podcast
there's always news from Mars John well
there's always news from a have see
Wimbledon - which is the I don't how are
you
I'm good I'm good how are you doing yeah
I don't know I don't even know anymore
I'm writing a lot and I'm inside of the
story and so when I get when I get
frustrated with the story I feel
frustrated with every other facet of my
life but I will say in in weather news
here in Indianapolis the post Taylor
Swift beauty that we have been
experiencing we're just clinging to it
we're just barely holding on the sky is
still blue but the temperature is
dropping it's a little worrisome I'm
beginning to think that fall might be in
the air how are things in Montana uh
it's actually very beautiful here it's
definitely fall lots of color on the
trees and I am doing good I just we did
nerdcon stories it turned out to go
really well it was a treat for me
because I got to hang out with a bunch
of great people and and and watch lots
of cool things happen on a stage that I
was like I would think it'd be funny if
we did this and it turned out I was
right well and occasionally wrong
sometimes but mostly right yeah I just I
don't want you to be praising yourself
too thoroughly it's only becoming well
it it had very little to do with me I
just put people on a stage and crossed
my fingers and in it and and I was very
pleased to have all of our all of our
guests and all of our attendees totally
come on their a-game and make a good
thing happen and everybody was just down
to clown it was fun I really liked the
attendees of nerdcon stories I have to
say I felt like it was a good and
gracious bunch of people who were
positive and enthusiastic and it was
really that's what made it special for
me it was just
you know being around people who care
about stories in the same way that I do
I felt like I felt like I was kind of
with with my tribe it was it was a
wonderful it was a wonderful weekend and
thank you for it Hank the only downside
for me was that I was in a car race
against Maggie Steve on her a great
young adult novelist and I well I
crashed my car and-and-and erupted into
a fiery tomb of death but fortunately I
was pulled from it before I was injured
so other than that I would qualify the
weekend as an entire success well I have
to say in fairness to you you didn't
crash the car I did it you spun a
spun-out it didn't hit anyone ever hit I
mean you managed to control the are that
and you didn't you didn't slam into
anybody or anything but apparently the
stress of whatever of losing control of
them yaar caused I think the breakline
debris which then sprayed brake fluid
all over the the hot underside of the
car and apparently brake fluid is
flammable yeah so that happened yeah it
was uh you're right I didn't crash I
came within about six inches of crashing
into the wall but didn't and I was I was
very pleased with myself for about ten
seconds I was like look at that I
managed not to crash I even put the car
into reverse and I was going to keep
going and then I realized that I was on
fire well I I call that the cars fault
not yours do you have a short poem for
us I do it's Philip Larkin is Luke
Rustin is a request actually today
William requested the poem home is so
sad by Philip Larkin it's a bit of a
depressing poem I apologize for that
Hank I know that you prefer the the
funny stuff but this is home is so sad
by Philip Larkin home is so sad
it stays as it was left shaped to the
comfort of the last to go as if to win
them back instead bereft of anyone to
please it withers so having no heart to
put aside the theft and turn again to
what it started as a joyous shot at how
things ought to be long fallen wide you
can see how it was look at the pictures
and the cutlery the music and the piano
stool
vaz home is so sad by philip larkin Oh
home oh it is so sad well guess what
when you take out all of the people
because everything is impermanent yeah I
guess that's the sadness Hank the
underlying sadness of most stories is
that everything is impermanent I was
thinking today as I was writing that
that in a way like all stories are about
a not just all stories but also all of
life but but every story in one way or
another is about a plucky young hero
desperately trying to escape her fate
yep
and each of us is a plucky is a plucky
young person desperately trying to
escape our fate until we become
middle-aged there are lots of plucky
middle-aged people trying to escape
their fate right I know but the the only
choice is between being a plucky
middle-aged person trying to escape your
fate and just accepting it not that not
that I'm not that I'm frustrated by how
the writing is going at the moment or
anything maybe we should answer some
viewer questions in this incredibly
depressing humor podcast we have a
question from Renee who asks dear Hank
and John My partner and I will be
getting married in a couple of months
originally no why bother Renee what's
the point of being alive originally we
planned for it to be just the two of us
our officiant and our photographer to
keep things very casual stress-free and
meaningful to us to celebrate and as a
concession to our family and friends who
wanted to be there we decided to throw a
big party later the same day as time has
gone on we felt pressured to allow our
families to attend the actual ceremony
do you think we should stick to our guns
and do what we want
or will we regret it later it's a big
question Hank and I suspect that you and
I might actually disagree so I'm
interested to hear your thoughts I think
that I don't know Renee and I don't know
Renee's partner but I do know that
marriages are about more than just the
two people inside of them I I think that
no marriage is an island and I think
that it is important it was important to
me that I had
important people in my life there to
witness me making that super important
most important promise I've ever made
and that I've needed support from
outside of my marriage to make my
marriage work and I think that's that's
I think that's true for everyone and so
it's good to recognize that marriage is
about more than just the people getting
married and and a good way to do that
not the only way to do that is by having
those people there at the ceremony and
then in addition to in addition to that
in addition to the the the practical
needs of the people getting married
there they're also like you know it's it
is about more than just the two of you
in a way and I think that like if I was
a parent and my and my child was like
having the most important day of their
lives I would want to be there for that
and I feel I would feel bad about not so
my counter-argument is that it's not one
of the most important days of your life
that in fact like the day of your
wedding is is not one of the most
interesting or important days of your
marriage right it's the day that you
make a commitment to a marriage but all
the interesting cool stuff that happens
in a marriage and I completely agree
with you that no marriage is an island
and that marriage is every marriage
every successful marriage requires more
than than the support of more than two
people but like I don't think that the
wedding is that important like looking
back on my wedding day I just don't I
think I don't think I'm important but
how would you think that our mom would
answer that question how do you think
she would react to not being at your
wedding
poorly cuz it's really like like yeah
the question there's the question of
like what is it for Renee and Renee's
partner there's also the question of
what is it for their parents Brian and
like how how devastated are they and I
don't know the answer to that question
yeah that I think that that my parents
would be crying yeah in silence yeah I
guess my advice would be to sort of
follow the path of least resistance
because I don't actually thinks it I
mean unless it's going to be super
stressful and miserable to have
family there because it's you know
broken or unapproved
relationships or unhealthy relationships
or whatever I really you know I
obviously you need the day you need that
day to be about you and your partner and
the commitment that you're making and
and you want that day to be special and
fun and as unstress 'fl as possible but
it
the family relationships are healthy and
functional and positive you know I I
would I would just be like you can come
but can you make it as unstress phul for
us as possible that's what I would say
yeah yeah and in a lot of ways it may be
it may end up being more stressful to
not have them there just because you're
creating your cried in in striving for a
stress-free stress-free marriage you may
end up creating drama yeah yeah I mean
it's very it's sometimes it's very
difficult to know what is the path of
least drama it's always the path I try
to follow but you just sometimes you
don't know which path it is but I I
guess like my advice to people who are
getting married is always to think oh to
try to focus more on the marriage than
on the wedding because weddings Pass and
marriages if you're lucky
don't pass until you do oh it's all
about death here on to your Hank and
John sorry I just I noticed that we'd
almost answered an entire question
without talking about the universality
of death give us another question
alright this question comes from Matt
who writes dear John and Hank I've been
thinking a lot about the intelligence of
animals compared to that of humans I
realized that every day my cat knows
where to get its food and knows to eat
it but there's so much it could never
know no matter how hard it tried its
brain could never possibly comprehend
the company that manufactures the food
or the nutritional value of the food or
the fact that I find it cheaper kind
because student loans are a thing anyway
I'm rambling my point is are we just
cats or Healy staring out into the
universe looking right out at something
that we will never actually be able to
comprehend no matter how hard we try
that's my kind of question Matt
yeah that's like I was looking at my cat
today and I realized that maybe we know
nothing well I do think that we know
more than your cat Matt no disrespect to
your cat but you know this is a matter
of degrees of gray I think the great
thing about humans is that we can
collaborate and not just you know not
not just in simple straightforward ways
like me saying to Matt Matt if we work
together to pick up this log we can pick
it up but we neither of us can pick it
up alone but also collaborating across
space and time being able to you know
collaborate for instance with Socrates
that's a huge or like being able to know
the laws of Hammurabi it's a huge
advantage that no other species enjoys
and that does make us special and I
don't think that we are just cats but I
do think that we are looking out at the
universe and seeing it through very
limited eyes of course and and also
seeing it in a kind of human centric way
and that seems to me inevitable and not
like not particularly tragic or
horrifying or anything it's just part of
part of being a person is that you
you're sort of stuck inside of person
this yeah it's it's often very jarring
to me when I realized that the way that
I've been understanding myself and my
place in the universe in my
relationships with people is is mu is
much more influenced by my culture and
by just sort of the you know the the the
lizard brain ways that we operate and
and see the world than it is on like my
you know my constructed and beautiful
psyche and and like whatever my ego is
like whatever the thing that I I think I
am turns out to be a lot simpler than
the thing that I actually am sometimes
but we're also pretty cool I mean we
have been like I don't I don't know what
we're missing but we figured out a lot
and we continue to figure out stuff and
I feel like that that's that path is
going to continue getting developed for
a long long time and we will not stop
learning
things and you know in a way you know
our sort of like looking at it the
universe is is you know maybe a little
bit like like cats looking at food and
not thinking about where the food came
from but but really the the complicated
things the really difficult problems
aren't aren't the universe they're all
going on in our own brains and and in
the interactions between brains and
that's where all the cool stuff is and
also where all of the mystery is in a
lot of ways thank you ever think about
the fact that your brain is made of meat
like your brain is edible everything
ever all of your hopes and dreams I
could eat them yeah well you could eat
the thing in which the hopes and dreams
that the platform in which they exist
but you couldn't eat them themselves
they would cease existing before they
got into your mouth I think our culture
around zombies and stuff really boils
down to that like our contemporary
obsession with zombies is about two
things first the feeling that you know
we may in fact not be running the show
in quite the way that we think we are
that like we may not be in control of
our own thoughts and desires and quite
the same way that we think we are and
then second that like our like ourselves
or what we think of as the self which is
located in the brain is edible yeah I
mean that is eat your brains the eating
of brains is definitely a definitely
comes from there in a lot of ways comes
from the place of realizing that that
our the the the meat that contains
ourselves is just meat god this is a
funny podcast let's have another
question it's it's a really funny pod
you know I'll give you another question
John
I really like liked this one and I want
to talk about it you won't maybe have
much to say but I hope I'm interested to
see what you do say oh and asks dear
Hank and John this might be a mostly
Hank question if my body temperature is
about 96 degrees then why does 96 degree
weather feel so hot why doesn't it feel
neutral I hope that makes sense well
first off oh and I am concerned because
your body temperature
Leeloo should be at least ninety seven
point five degrees and the fact that it
is 96 degrees as me worried all right
now that we've gotten through the
insufferable paedon sufferable pedantry
what's your actual I know I'm not being
pedantic I am as a hypochondriac
genuinely concerned I cannot tell you
how many times I have taken my own
temperature and found it to be between
96 and 97 degrees and called my
physician I am i back at me that is not
a joke
oh okay anything else for Owen
again I really think that that's worth
checking out okay but anything else any
any actual answer to the question
assuming that Owen means that Owens body
temperature is 98.6 degrees no I can't
get past my concern yeah that's not true
John you can't get past your concern you
just don't want to because you don't
want to admit that you don't know the
answer because I'm smarter than you no
we're just different kinds of smart all
right mom's been telling me that my
whole life oh man so John let's start
out by saying is there any situation you
could imagine being in and in something
that was you know maybe say like 90
degrees but it doesn't feel hot to you
well yes of course what's that 90 degree
water correct so what's the difference
between water and air well there are a
number of differences you pedantic but
what in this case what do you think
might be the difference that causes that
that difference to be oh my god I'm
being reminded of how much I hated
middle school science because it was
full of rhetorical questions asked by a
know-it-all teacher who was like and
what do you think and I'm just like you
know the answer just tell me sorry we're
gonna have to bleep a bunch of that
because I got really genuinely angry at
Hank
well I like walking through the process
of figuring it out what is different
between water and air a number of things
but I bet the inside of my body has a
ton of water in it whereas the inside of
my body has relatively little air yeah
that that's that's kind of the the thing
it's that there is there there's far
more water in water than there is air
and air hmm
so there are you know there's just
there's a massively large amount of
molecules in water compared to the
number of molecules and in air so when
you when you're in the air your body is
it is always no matter where you are
your body is always trying to cool
itself off because the existence of a
human being in the world requires the
the consumption of energy and the
consumption of energy always produces
some heat and that heat continues to
raise your body and if you didn't have
any way to cool down you would overheat
and die and that is why and the body has
been designed to operate optimally in
70-degree air because it's you know
because actually because that's sort of
the average temperature of the earth but
now that we have anything to say about
it we are gonna get that number up
people are always like Oh human beings
like we don't reach for the stars but we
are reaching for the stars by destroying
the atmosphere and raising the
temperature of the planet we are
literally getting closer to the stars it
didn't make any sense to me but I'll let
it be look I mean am I am I wrong that
if we if we just thin out the atmosphere
just a little bit that will be closer to
the stars well we're not thinning out
the atmosphere at all one we're making
it thicker that's the problem - no it
wouldn't make us closer to the stars
we're getting further from the storm
we're I'm not an astronomer I'm just
reaching for a metaphor here so your
body so the answer is that there isn't
that that we're always trying to cool
ourselves off because we produce heat
and there isn't that much yeah
isn't that much air in air yeah so
you're always trying you're always
trying to cool off and so you need
molecules to touch you that are colder
than you are so that you can dump your
heat into those molecules that's why
when it's windy there are actually more
molecules hitting you and also the sort
of layer of molecules that have already
sucked your heat out get blown away and
are replaced by new molecules that are
more of the original temperature which
is why fans work but if you're in water
there's just so many more molecules that
it's much easier for your heat to
disperse to them so if you get in water
that's 98.6 degrees it basically feels
like nothing is touching you at all
which is fascinating thanks for the
question Owen sorry that John hated it
so much I liked the question Owen I'm
not a I'm I didn't like Hank sands I
wanted to study fluid my issue is I like
it when it's my issue is not with Owen
my issue is with that like the the like
rhetorical know-it-all approach to
answering questions like when when we
are discussing poetry do I ever say like
Hank what is the rhythm of your heart
and start from there no I just like well
from my perspective I think this is
important so I apologize for continuing
to talk about it but from my perspective
like I like to think about how people
figure this out in the first place or
how I might figure it out without having
someone tell it to me and so when I was
asked that question from Owen I didn't
know the answer to that question but I
did know that getting in 90-degree water
feels cool so starting from that I
wanted to figure out like what is it
about 90 degree water that makes it cool
that might make me give me insight into
why 90 degree air seems hot uh-huh I
still feel I still feel like a middle
school student which is the way I I like
feeling least in the whole world that I
can understand that completely let's
move on to a new question this question
is from Daniel who asks dear John and
Hank is there a way to enjoy slow books
in other words books that have a droning
and otherwise uninteresting tone I'd
love to read Lord of the Rings but I've
heard that it's very slow and easy to
lose focus while reading it that that
question took an unexpected turn from
Hank because when I think of slow books
I think of a this wonderful book that I
read in college called Islamization and
native religion in the golden horde
which is about how the Uzbek people came
to identify as Muslims and it's about
800 pages long and it's it's definitely
got some slow parts it's got some really
enjoyable but it's um it's a dry read
and it took tremendous focus for me to
read it and yet it's still one of the
most important books I've ever read like
I think about it all the time Lord of
the Rings on the other hand I found to
be a pretty rip-roaring kind of read but
I think that III think maybe this speaks
to something that's changed in the
culture in the last 15 years and changed
about the the kind of attentiveness that
that humans specialized in having kind
of been altered by the internet yeah or
just by the constant availability of
things to enjoy more than more than the
Internet itself right right by the by
scrolling the idea of yeah scrolling
being able to sort of permanently scroll
through entertainment yes I mean I think
that it is important to be able to take
some steps back from from the
consumption of media and to be inside of
your own brain for a while and maybe if
that is something that you are
interested in doing it might make slower
experiences more enjoyable I love to
read a lot but it took me a long time to
get where to there and I you know I
think that I think there's an amount of
like just letting it be and saying like
okay well this is what I'm gonna do for
the next hour and if you read in your
mind wanders then that's okay let your
mind wander and when you notice that
your mind has wandered bring it back and
if it takes you you know an hour to read
a chapter or if it takes I don't know
how long a chapter of The Lord of the
Rings is anymore but if it takes you
what you would consider to be too long
to be enjoying this thing but remember
that you also spent time with
your mind wandering with your mind doing
things and working out problems and
considering what happened to it today
and there's nothing wrong with that
yeah I mean I I completely agree with
you I don't think reading is something
that you are born knowing how to do
obviously and it's not something that
you like it's something that gets better
with practice and gets much worse
without practice I found that in my own
life like since Henry and Alice were
bored it's I have or I don't I spend
less time reading than I used to and as
a result my reading has gotten worse my
reading comprehension is worse my
reading speed is worse my read fewer
books per per year and I think I read
them less well that's generously than I
used to and but I don't think that's
just because I have kids now I also
think it's because I spend too much time
passively ingesting media and then the
the active work of reading feels much
harder for me than it used to so that's
something I think a lot about and I do
it does concern me I love the I love the
Internet and I appreciate the enjoyment
that distraction culture provides me but
I do worry a little bit about the fact
that I feel like overall I kind of lead
a less engaged wife the night that I
used to and reading is is one strong
place where I see that I like our answer
I have a question from Maddie that I
think is important what is gonna be no
fun
Maddie asks dear Hank and John my
younger sister recently graduated from
college with a degree in marketing and
PR she elected not to go to grad school
right away and instead wanted to work
for a year and decide whether she wanted
to get a masters degree in however
instead of looking for a job she got
involved in a pyramid scheme she talks
passionately about it to everyone who
listened and managed to convince most of
the people she knows to spend lots of
money and buy into the program her
degree combined with her personality
makes her a great salesperson
she spent a lot of money every month on
the program and is spending more and
more time trying to build her business
instead of looking for a job do you have
any advice on how I can talk to her
without upsetting her and making her
understand make her understand that her
decision to stay in that business might
not be the best one for her I really
hate pyramid schemes so I wanted to
answer this question yeah I mean I don't
know what to say I think
it's it's extremely difficult when you
are inside of a pyramid scheme a lot of
times to understand that you are inside
of a pyramid scheme there's also
something of a fine line between a
pyramid scheme and direct sales programs
right like I I guess maybe we should
start off by defining what a pyramid
scheme is so here it is in its basic
form I say to my brother Hank Hank if
you give me $10 I will teach you how to
get people to give you $10 and and then
Hank goes forth with that knowledge and
and but but it and then also if you
could just send me one of the dollars
that you make every time you get someone
you teach someone how to make $10 and
then Hank teaches to people how to make
$10 well I have now made $12 just just
by teaching Hank how to make $10 and
then but but if more people convince
more people how to make $10 I will make
much more than $12 because I am at the
top of the pyramid the people at the
bottom of the pyramid which would be a
progressively larger number of people
will eventually find that they are
unable to find people to teach how to
make $10 but a lot of times pyramid
schemes or pyramid shaped businesses
aren't just about like you know that
basic fraud that they may be about
selling you know selling something
selling some physical good you know
health bars and that's where it gets
that's where it gets complicated you
often find that the physical good that's
being involved in the pyramid scheme is
is basically just sort of there as a as
a way to make it seem more legitimate
and so it will be like ridiculously
overpriced in some way and really it's
about you know people trying to get
other people to give them money because
there's this dream of getting rich and
that is that is why they are often
called get-rich-quick schemes they're
also called multi-level marketing
schemes because the idea is that your
your your marketing at all these
multiple levels and sort of sending
money up and if the the sooner you can
get in on the game
the better it is for you it's it's very
difficult to like these things are
designed in really clever ways and and
it's kind of it can often be something
that like it's almost like something you
should imagine as like it's something
that happened to a person like getting
hit by a car that it's very difficult to
control and then it makes in and then it
makes them sort of like you know more
difficult to deal with for a while
because they are that was a bad example
yeah it's more like buying into a cult
than it is like getting hit by a car I
can't think of a single way in which
it's well I yeah what I'm trying to say
it's it's it's a little like something
that just that happens to a person and
it's very difficult to have it unhappen
to them and especially because once they
you know get involved and they start
recruiting friends and family they have
to admit to themselves that they have
gotten their friends and family involved
in this thing that is in fact you know
very bad for them and and and like
admitting that especially when you've
got all of this sort of like
psychological cool like hook enos that
that these schemes use to convince
people that they are in fact legitimate
but it's business enterprise admitting
that becomes very difficult and and it
tends to come in the form of like
eventual failure when you no longer are
making money from the scheme and then
embarrassment in shame which comes along
with having previously alienated
yourselves from all of your loved ones
who you tried to get involved with the
scheme and either either got annoyed
with you or or you know bought in but
then failed sooner than they did because
it tends to fail upward so it fails from
the bottom up and and and that is just a
terrible thing to have happen but
because of the psychological hooks of
the the multi-level marketing scheme
it's like arguing with people about it
tends to make them get even more
obsessed and interested in it and sort
of believe in it especially once they've
bought in enough that they're spending a
lot of their own money and they don't
want to admit they've made a mistake and
so they've gotten their friends and
family involved and they don't want to
admit to themselves that they've done a
bad thing to their friends and family as
a sister a lot alike basically what you
can do is is to be supportive in in a
difficult time like that's kind of what
this is it's a difficult time and just
because they haven't realized it's a
difficult time doesn't mean that it
isn't and and and then it will in the
future be a much more difficult time as
they come to realize that the difficulty
and and sort of like that you know like
that they've spent a lot of their time
and energy on on something that was a
bad use of their time and energy and
money yeah I mean I think in general you
know there's lots of situations in life
where you have to love people who are
making mistakes I mean you also have to
accept of course that you might be wrong
that this might be a completely
legitimate business enterprise it
probably isn't but it is in her mind and
so you just have to lovingly not support
someone which is very difficult to do
but I think it's it when it's gonna be
really important is when it all falls
apart for her to know that that you
still love her and that anything that
can kind of decrease the shame spiral
decreases the power of you know not just
pyramid schemes but lots of lots of
different things that prey on human
psychology and and human emotion so I
think you know loving someone and not
judging them is incredibly powerful
I agree John okay if we have another
question this one is from Brenna who
writes Dear John and Hank so my roommate
and I just moved into an on-campus
apartment and we are cooking dinner for
ourselves for the first time my question
is at what point in adulthood do you get
over the fear of giving your dinner
guests salmonella not there yet
yep yeah I'm not there I do not know you
you definitely passed 38 that's all we
can say for sure Brenna I can't see out
of the future but I worry I mean I spend
a lot of time cleaning cooking surfaces
and trying to make sure that no raw food
has been touched in any way without
extensive hand washing yeah I
I I think that the number one way to get
over this fear is to work in a
commercial kitchen either at a at a
restaurant probably the most likely
circumstance that you would be doing
that and then you would know a great
deal and you would have a lot of
experience with not giving people
Salmonella and but without that well but
also having worked at having worked at a
restaurant Hank I can tell you that you
don't always learn how to not give fee
for Salmonella you got to make the
mistake fortunately I don't mean to
crush all your dreams but you you should
worry when you go out to eat you should
make sure that that hamburger is well
and truly cooked I had I had norovirus a
few years ago this 24 hour vomiting and
diarrhea illness that we were talking
earlier about how my wedding day I don't
remember it as a particularly important
day in my marriage I do remember my day
with norovirus as a particularly
interesting and important day in my
marriage because me too actually yeah no
there is you don't know true love until
you've suffered through norovirus with
you with your partner and you know
looking back on that day I often think
like am I overreacting about food safety
and then I think no no I'm not I it was
an amazing day for me my norovirus day
because I was just laying in bed and
then I and then I and then I was like
Katherine I don't feel well and then I
sat up in bed and then I exploded and
and she handled it just so well yeah
like like I got out of the bathroom a
half an hour later and like the room was
for the most part clean like wow you
just you just frickin did that you were
like okay time to time to take care of
stuff it's done yeah wow I was super
impressed and yeah hadn't gotten that
chance to like really like see what she
was made of right then I I remember that
I ate I ate a bowl of chili
wonderful a home-cooked chili I'd had a
whole food sushi for lunch and then I
had a wonderful ball of chili and I was
just going downstairs to get my standard
second bowl of chili which I've never in
my life eaten just one bowl of chili
what's the point and so I'm telling
downstairs to eat my standard second
bowl of chili and I thought to myself
you know there's something a little
weird in my stomach right now
and maybe just maybe I should hold off
on this second bowl of chili and then I
thought nah I'm fine I'm probably fine I
ate about five bites with my second bowl
of chili and then I was like I am going
to throw up and not like eventually but
like in the next 10 seconds it was it
was literally the day after Thanksgiving
so I had done the thing where you eat
all of the Thanksgiving leftover Oh God
so I was just filled to the top with
with cranberry juice it oh yeah and
stuffing yeah tato
oh yeah yeah no I remember those I
remember the seaweed from the whole food
sushi like at the end you know at the
bottom after everything after all oh man
John this episode needs a trigger
warning Oh came back up in order it was
brutal oh man thank God we finally found
something funny in this stupid humor
podcast Oh
norovirus anyway norovirus is not caused
by contaminated food usually so it's
caused by eating someone else's poop or
puke oh that's right usually so if it
does if it if it makes you feel bad to
think that like oh god I definitely ate
someone's poop there's a chance that you
ate someone's value yeah I mean one of
the things that really gets to me about
being a person who you know like has
this mind and ostensibly this soul but
is stuck inside of a physical body is
that I I mean like how many people's
poop have I eaten hundreds thousands
seriously that's not a rhetorical
question I'm at you told me how many
bacteria there are in my body a few
episodes ago I'm asking you now how many
people's poop if I eaten IV a lot right
like more than five probably probably
probably over a hundred a bunch of
strangers I would say I will definitely
over a hundred I mean probably most I'm
sure that the vast majority of times you
eat someone's poop there's no negative
consequence at all and you probably eat
your own poop every single day
just just cross-contamination is too
common you know the other the other
thing I was thinking recently Hank as I
was kayaking in the White River the
White River is a beautiful river in
Indianapolis but when it rains more than
a quarter of an inch in the city they
just directly dump all of the poop in
the sewers into the river and that's not
an exaggeration that is a fact it
happens maybe like 50 or 60 times a year
and I was going and I was going up
something of a rapid and a large amount
of water entered my mouth like probably
I would say between 3 and 6 drops of
water entered my mouth simultaneously
and I obviously I tried to spit it out
as much as possible but I mean there
could be hundreds of people's poop just
in those three drops of water so almost
certainly there was that what I'm saying
is that like if you if you like me have
a fear of contamination it's not
irrational like it's not one of the
things that really bothers me about
people well it's a little bit of
rational and that it's unavoidable and
that it is usually it is usually fine
well no but the fact is I am
contaminated so it is incorrect for like
for instance a psychotherapist to tell
me that my fear of contamination is is
irrational when when in fact I am
constantly contaminated with hundreds of
other people's stuff oh well yeah it's
not the fear I'm saying that you're
you're the reality that you are
contaminated is absolutely true Oh God
the fear of it is what is irrational
let's move on to ask what you have to
update it we have to we have to let
everyone know that this episode of Hank
dear Hank and John is sponsored by other
people's poop
[Laughter]
other people's poop it's everywhere and
you eat it Oh God this episode of dear
Hank and John is also sponsored by your
wedding your wedding yeah this episode
of dear Hank and John is brought to you
by the totally not a pyramid scheme Hank
and John Green magical lip balm company
hahaha thank and John magical lip balm
company $14 lip balm but boy is it good
send it send it our way and we'll teach
you how to sell other people magical lip
balm and of course this episode of dear
Hank and John is brought to you by
middle school science teachers middle
school science teachers knowing it all
since the beginning of time ok Hank we
have time for one last question before
we get to the news from Mars and AFC
Wimbledon it's a vitally important
question it comes from Sarah who writes
dear John and Hank is honesty really
always the best policy or are there some
situations in which discretion is best
for everyone
Sarah this is such an important question
because I can't tell you how much I wish
I could go back in time to the time
before Hank told me that most of the
cells in my body are not mine it's
impossible for me to express the
blissful ignorance that I enjoyed for
the first 38 years of my life assuming
that most of me was in fact me and not
microorganisms so yes honesty is not
always the best policy discretion is
often the best yeah I agree I do enjoy
being honest when when when others think
that it is not a good idea it's yeah I
also enjoy that when other people do it
and I I think that it can cut to the
chase a lot especially in business and
when there's a lot of posturing going on
or in other circumstances where there
might be a lot of posturing going on but
I think in normal everyday well Sarah's
question to be fair is about affection
you know I like romantic interest it was
she did not originally intended to be a
question about the human bio huh but at
this point I can't read any other
question I can't read any question in a
different context but yeah but yeah I
think I think in the world of affections
it's often it's often quite useful to
get to honesty quickly but but but of
course there is a real and undeniable
risk of loss in that as well yeah
especially if you especially if you know
that there that person is already in a
relationship or that they are definitely
not interested to you or any of the
other you know if they are interested in
people of that different gender than you
are then you know that is a it's often
like you know my suggestion is not like
oh don't be honest but yet don't be
honest but also figure out a way to not
be so affectionate toward them I often
like to to examine people what I don't
agree with this advice that sometimes
you should be honest it depends on the
situation oh yes I agree
take away all of the things I said
you're basically just told Sarah like
don't know don't tell them don't tell
the person you like that you like that
well maybe tell them it depends on the
situation Sarah honestly don't don't
take any of our advice seriously do you
know how many people's poop I've eaten
Sarah hundreds I was this understanding
the question I apologize I didn't I
didn't yes oh I I am surrounded by a
terrible darkness Hank what's the news
from Mars ah
there are pebbles on Mars John oh my god
are you serious yeah but Devils in
addition to there being pebbles they are
they are pebbles of a certain size and
coarseness that indicate that not only
did they exist inside of a river but
they existed inside of a river that
flowed for miles and miles and miles and
and those rocks flowed down with that
River for miles over a long period of
time not over not over a short period
not in a mass flood event but in in a
circumstance that looked a lot like one
we might have here on earth
that is incredibly exciting I don't even
know what to say I'm breathless to know
that there are pebbles on Mars that look
a little bit like the pebbles that we
have right here on earth
including in South London where AFC
Wimbledon play almost every Saturday
well Hank the news from AFC Wimbledon is
uh since is about as interesting as the
news from Mars this week AFC Wimbledon
last week played Oxford United you know
Oxford that's where they have that fancy
College in England I've never thought
much of uh of the Football Club that
hails from Oxford but they did beat they
did beat AFC Wimbledon 1 to nothing it's
just that there was a distressing
distressing game and indeed like you
can't help but be a bit worried by our
lack of goal production but we're taking
on more camp this weekend which will be
in the past as as we listen to the
podcast so let us hope that we have a
glorious victory to celebrate because
you know I would really I I I want the
narrative of AFC Wimbledon to be a club
on the rise but then I would also accept
the narrative of AFC Wimbledon to be a
club in comfortable stasis but the lack
of offensive production is a bit
worrisome particularly given how much
talent we have up front with the likes
of auda by a walk and phenoix so yeah
that's the news from AFC Wimbledon what
what what why do you think why do you
that is John why do you think that that
the the Wimbley czar having a hard time
getting getting the ball in the net
I appreciate you your feigned interest
first off I just like to say that but so
I haven't been able to watch a game this
year on account of how they believe it
or not they don't put fourth tier
English football on TV in the United
States but my understanding from fans
and from reading everything on the
website and from listening to the games
on the radio is that we just don't have
a lot of control of the ball in midfield
so really the game of soccer is a game
of think of it as a game of three thirds
right you've got your defensive third
you've got the the middle third of the
pitch and then you've got your attacking
third the ability to get it from the
defensive third
when you recover possession through the
middle third into the attacking third
that's a sin that's the entire game like
the whole the whole game is actually
played in in midfield so we have good
finishers of the ball but we don't have
we just haven't had a ton of luck
getting sustained possession in that
attacking third because it requires
traveling through the midfield does that
make sense it does it does yeah so
anyway I'm sure that there are brighter
days to come I mean at least I hope so
this has been one depressing comedy
podcast well and it's been a depressing
Papa comedy podcast in which we learned
what well Hank we learned that norovirus
can teach you more about your marriage
than your wedding can yeah we learned we
learned that there's something about the
number of molecules that hit your body
that controls how well you can cool off
and the cooling off is important damn
that John does not want to be back in
middle school in any way at all ever at
all and of course we learned that the
rivers that no longer flow on Mars once
made pebbles which is sort of beautiful
now that I think about it this is this
has been dear Hank and John if you would
like to send us questions you can do so
at dear Hank and John at gmail.com
isn't it just Hank and John at gmail.com
oh you're right you're right sure no
it's fun you can set it to dear Hank and
John in gmail.com to just we won't read
them because that's not our email
address this podcast is edited by
Nicholas Jenkins
it is a fleet music that you're hearing
now is from the remarkable gunnarolla
and as they say in our hometown don't
forget to heal
[Music]